hey fellow Geeks it's me again Debbie
and welcome back to our Channel today
we're diving into the exciting wall of
this mini Tech as we take a closer look
at the Apple watch OS 10. first up let's
start with what we all adore watch faces
the watch OS 10 brings a burst of
creativity of the new phases of Snoopy
and Woodstock and Palette just look at
the really cute Snoopy designs this pack
has I'm still not too sure how many
designs there are upon waking my Apple
watch up because each time I think hey
that is it more animated designs start
popping up I'd say they may be about 20
adorable Snoopy animated designs that
will melt your heart and for all you
color enthusiasts palette offers an
array of gradients and Hues to match
your style with many colors to choose
from and beautiful gradients it is no
wonder why Apple included this new
design in simply turn the crown and
select the color combination you want I
personally love these colors the most
not to mention you can also customize
the complications on each four of the
corners to switch between these Beauties
just hold down on the screen and swipe
to the one you want it's that easy
switching app views just got smoother
want to swap between list and grid a
simple scroll down on the list of apps
followed by a tap on grid view or the
other way around does the trick it's
like having a secret Tech handshake
alternatively changing the app view can
also be done under general settings
followed by app View and then swap
between list or grid moving on instead
of dragging your fingers up on the
screen to access the control center
Apple has now changed it to the side
button all it takes is one press of the
side button and voila instant access to
your Wi-Fi settings flashlight timers
and more for those of you who have been
so used to the watch OS 9 and below this
might take a little getting used to so
then what's new now that the control
center has moved to the side button
let's talk about the new Apple smart
stack with a simple swipe up on the
screen or a Twist of the digital Crown
widgets reveal themselves you can view
the weather calendar activity and more
and here's the cool part you can
personalize your stack by adding or
removing widgets just press and hold to
shift things around before we get into
even more features geek culture is
supported by you the community and brand
to help us improve our videos so please
stick around for this sponsored message
here at geek culture we've tested plenty
of chairs but Secret Life gaming chairs
remain one of our favorites whether it's
for work or play they feel great to lean
back against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head and back
to the arms and even something for your
butt this mix of format function helps
the Titan Evo 2020 to deliver the best
seating experience like no other for
more information check out secretlab.co
there are a couple of modifications
iterations to the design and viewing of
the
some of them include the weather app it
definitely looks more aesthetically
pleasing compared to how it looked
previously and it now gives you a better
in-depth update next the activity app
you can now use the activity app to view
your weekly summary and scroll through
the different pages to see your movement
exercise standing duration steps taken
and your last locked activity and oh the
heart rate apps new animation oh my gosh
it's like Tech meets sophistication
speaking of heart we all need to take
care of our hearts mind and soul and
with the mindfulness app getting a
revamp you can now Journal how you feel
on the go previously there were only two
options reflect and breathe now you can
log your state of mind you can choose
between logging how you're feeling right
now or how you felt overall today scroll
through to see what best reflects your
mood personally I feel Pleasant Next
Step you can add what best describes
your feelings and I feel relieved you
can select more than one next select
what has been the biggest impact on you
for me it has been Health you can go
through all these steps or simply skip
them if you don't feel like adding
anything further other than your mood I
do feel that it is a great way to
monitor your emotions and know when
things are getting a little bit too
overwhelming and perhaps maybe then seek
out comfort from your loved ones or
friends now that we've gotten our
emotions in check here's to health
specifically cyclists
watch OS 10 is truly your cycling buddy
the Apple watch now syncs with other
Bluetooth accessories like bluetooth
available stationary bikes it tracks
your power meter pedals heart rate
Cadence speed and power plus your iPhone
turns into a bike computer displaying
all the metrics you need there's more on
the horizon name drop only works on the
iPhone IOS 17 update for now but get
ready for name drop on the watch OS 10
where you can simply send your contact
to someone new by just pointing your
phones toward each other I do have to
add one more thing and that is ever
since updating to the watch OS 10 the
battery life depletes a little more than
usual it is now however still in the
early stages of the OS 10. hopefully
Apple resolves this problem with the
future updates and there you have it
folks the Apple watch OS 10 is a
symphony of innovation a blend of
convenience and a whole lot of heart
which feature are you most excited about
drop your thoughts in the comments below
and make sure to smash the like And
subscribe button for more thrilling Tech
Updates this is Debbie and until next
time don't forget to geek out
[Music]
okay
are we done
we were awkward hello
[Music]